adesso a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo dio sono fa vigeva vedo che
c'è qualcuno che mi indovina qui è bello
che pensate a me anche quando non ci
sono
oggi siamo tornati su a chi netto che è
praticamente in grado di indovinare
quello di personaggi che pensiamo che ci
immaginiamo quindi tipo se io penso a
rocco siffredi lui anzi ero così fai
giochiamo il suo personaggio viene
dall'italia ha voglia e famoso grazie a
youtube conto se ingenua caro mio
proprio grazie a youtube però la
premessa è la giusta
no il suo personaggio è femmina ma avrai
capito per me no no no no cantante no fa
parte di find hi tech freddi stare in
compagnia libera che cazzo cènova cosa
vuol dire un attore porto si eccolo è
che tra l'altro non mi hanno fatto
notare vince una foto che ho io che sono
tipo messo ecco i sì e rochus bravissimo
indovinato madonna 246 testa efficaci o
pensano tutti i ragazzi si muove nello
scorso episodio ho fatto me stesso un po
di roba da volta ho deciso di far fare a
voi nel senso che ho scritto su facebook
riproviamo un po di scelte vostre
ragazzi facciamo che giocate questa
volta io io faccio da tramite prova
giapponese di san gennaro
come fa trova dai e femmina no e padre
non lo so ma che ne so
di nazionalità italiana no lavora ancora
non so non ho idea e giappone come cazzo
è possibile ma come cazzo è possibile
come cazzo hai fatto non è come di punto
in bianco sono uscito chiedendomi 6
giapponese cioè a capo devo pensare
anche che cazzo ne so il bruno marzo
avrete avresti indovinato prima quello
giapponese non è possibile
la cosa non l'ho capita ragazzi però
giulia scrive olimpia ma donia
signora orgasmo di avanti un altro va
bene proviamo olimpia ragazzi si è mai
sposato si è sposata non ricordi indossa
vestiti femminili
se ha condotto un programma a norma ci
siamo quasi ai capelli biondi ma class
ex sia i capelli biondi cioè capire
perché si fa parte del programma ragazzi
non è possibile ma non è possibile come
cazzo face allora donna donna capelli
biondi poteva essere chiunque come cazzo
di venuto in mente che quella di avanti
un altro non ho capito mi sente col
microfono e ha chiesto per indovinare o
non lo capisco alice sabato o facciamo
una hit che so di più o meno è maschio
si scherza vissuto in italia se il suo
personaggio laicità in victor ius non
credo è stato scoperto grazie a youtube
no canta non lo so non penso alla
partecipata si abbaia perchè abbaia
cataldi se mi fai la domanda su miss
italia perché quella dopo mi chiedi se
abbaia non è che a miss italia ci
partecipano le [ __ ] cioè stai calmo
no però che cazzo ha vinto miss in abito
di seta perché se mette allora no no
posso tornare indietro voglio mettere
che abbaia voglio dire che chi fornisce
fuori stata indovinata 1942 volte
fantastico cerca clapis che si suicida
sul marciapiede ragazzi ma che di cosa
vi fate a ok mattia va bene così non ti
faccio domande non penso ed esca fuori
la foto di lui che si suicida però è una
donna
no però va bene questo passaggio è nato
in italia se attualmente più di 34 apre
bravo clapis tmt le date di nascita
complimenti limite se devo chiedere a
clapis in che anno è nato perché se no
non mi risponde quelli che fede quanti
anni hai vederselo chiedere domande alla
gente per per andare su a chi nei torce
a 28 prof
grazie per 28 28 28 che domande al
clavis in diretta per fare laghi nator
grande club in un applauso suo
personaggio è stato scoperto grazie a
youtube
si è di torino no quello sono io a che
fare col mondo videogiochi una cosa sono
sempre io è un cantante si è stato il
cantante ha cantato la canzone la
foresta
ah no quelle di ale buffon no no no non
c'entro cazzo un pare solo di notte cosa
è batman clapis ha vinto un golden globe
non però ci è vicino e lasciandoli one
direction ragazzi si è scoperto che in
realtà gamer il sempre stato clapis ha
creato piano minchia 40 minuti per
indovinare mi clapis 6 40 minuti per
indovinare clapis 5 secondi per
indovinare quello giapponese spiegate
nella sta cosa bravi bravi bravi dj
perché gli danno del dj cerca papi j va
bene è programmabile sta cosa è strana
non ho mai trovato il suo personaggio
indossa vestiti femminili no per l'amor
di dio ha figli si ha scritto la saga
ora è già tanto leggere un giocatore
delle mie amiche a mio padre ci
mancherebbe usa nome d'arte si ha la
barba a volte un cantante rap a che fare
con fa vicenzi e calvo cosa è calvo
esatto sergio studi padre non c'è la
foto
cos'è non è mio padre è la madonna
illuminato mille volte chi è che pensa a
mio padre mille volte cerca la gallina
di banderas è un animale no assise
animale cazzo di di piccola taglia se è
nato senza piedi è un pupazzo no ha il
pelo
no ho segnato assegnato certo era ovvio
sempre visto galline segnava il gol fa
parte dei green day cosa lo sto capendo
io della vita fatemi capire perché mi fa
domande sugli animali chiedendomi quante
zampe anno e poi mi chiedono se fanno
parte dei green day 1 nei citati neri
potter no è una cazzo di gallina
vinto i mondiali di julio non ha vinto i
mondiali rosita è vero che vi fa le
domande tipo ha recitato in harry potter
fa parte dei green day e io mettono e
poi indovina rosita se sai che una cazzo
di gallina fa mille domande sulle
galline che cosa c'entra
noi green day ma se metto lo va a caso
che cosa esce capo a carissimo c'è
proprio robe papà di fuori da casa o sia
già avete visto avete visto tutti ho
schiacciato a caso ma come cazzo è
uscito mio padre c'è se una persona
cliccata stia caso su macchine tor s mio
padre perché scoppito matteo renzi io
saveri che lo cercano del giapponese
potevo cercare anche la voglia di
studiare quella non la trova nessuno
noi dobbiamo fissare i ragazzi non mi
piace per la città per rocco spero che
vi sia piaciuto e cosa sente subito
piaciuta seconda vita cento la pagina di
facebook a fine vita torna verità se non
se ne volesse iscrivere ci vediamo al
prossimo video del ragazzo